deepmind uses deep learning to restore
ancient greek texts a drug discovery
system has been abused to create
thousands and thousands of super toxic
compounds and gary marcus claims deep
learning is hitting a wall welcome to ml
news it's monday
[Music]
nvidia's gtc conference goes into its
next iteration now gtc is a company
conference like all of the big companies
they present all of their newest stuff
there but they also have a host of
external speakers and all kinds of
people that just give education and
talks about how they use deep learning
for various things now all of it is
obviously nvidia themed but i can
promise you the talks are interesting by
themselves as well the highlight of the
conference is obviously the keynote by
jensen huang and depending on when
you're watching this video the
conference is going on probably right
now and the best part is if you use my
link that's why culture.com gtc and you
use that to sign up for the conference
you can win a 3090 that has been hand
signed by jensen huang so the same
person that is giving the keynote will
have signed your gpu if you win it now
this is pretty cool all you have to do
is sign up using my link and then attend
at least one session and why not attend
the keynote the keynote will go into all
of the upcoming things of nvidia for
example is there gonna be something like
a 4090 how does it look like why do they
increase the first digit of 3090 and not
just make it the 3091 all the biggest
questions of humanity now other than new
architectures coming up there will also
be a lot of talks on the topics of
accelerated computing autonomous driving
anything to do with computer vision
rendering cyber security nvidia hardware
now powers almost all of deep learning
advances apart from some specialized
vendors so this is definitely a good
place to look another thing i want to
highlight is the nvidia omniverse
platform which is a high performance and
really good simulation physics and
rendering engine this includes pixar's
universal scene description technology
and can be used to do accurate
renderings and since synthetic data is
such a big deal in recent times this
could really be something to accelerate
your research if you are into simulated
data transferring to the real world it's
pretty cool and a lot of things can be
done with it and now the omniverse isn't
the metaverse per se but there is a
session that you can attend in gtc that
talks about the metaverse and how to
build virtual connected worlds and as
you can see one of the speakers is the
vp of omniverse so in the end
everything's somehow going to be
together there are even sessions called
connect with the experts where you get
one-on-one time with experts in a
certain area for example gpu performance
analysis and optimization this is first
come first serve so hurry up as i said
besides the keynote there is an entire
plethora of sessions that you can attend
these go from building large language
models to next generation rendering to
using ai for cyber security or
understanding how newest technologies
can help your business there's also more
specialized tracks such as focuses on
healthcare autonomous driving and other
areas registration is free and you can
put together your own little calendar
that reminds you whenever these sessions
are coming up again use my link to sign
up in order to win a 30-90 there's one
caveat you need to be in emea which is
europe middle east or africa in order to
qualify for the 30-90 raffle however
i've decided that anyone living outside
of these areas can also participate in
another raffle that i sponsor and that
will just give you some
some merch so inside me uh you can
participate for the 30 90 outside emilia
you can participate for the merge now if
you are in either bucket and you want to
be in the other bucket i'm sure we're
gonna do stuff in the future where you
can win to your heart's content but for
now this seems the most fairest
allocation of resources and remember you
have to attend a session in gtc in order
to qualify for the 3090.
deepmind has released a new blog post
called predicting the past with ithaca
now this is a system that restores
ancient texts namely ancient texts from
the greeks so throughout the years a lot
of these inscriptions in stone have gone
missing have been damaged and therefore
historians they need to tease out what
things could mean now this is obviously
a good application for something like a
language model so what ithaca does is it
takes in whatever is undamaged and a few
hints of where it needs to fill in
missing characters and it tries to
reconstruct these things not only will
it give an output that restores the
missing pieces of text but it will also
determine a probability distribution
over the geographical origins of this
piece of text as well as a chronological
attribution meaning it will estimate
when the text was written now it's
interesting to me as you can see right
here the input is just plain text i
would have guessed that they would use
some sort of computer visiony things as
well as maybe the greeks would have
written down some stuff in certain ways
in certain order but i'm not too
educated in ancient greek so this might
not have been the case after all what is
cool though is that the blog post goes
into a lot of detail not only about the
system itself and how good it is which
it undoubtedly is but how the
combination of humans and machines
together can outperform anyone alone
they talk a lot about how to build tools
in order for historians to be able to
effectively interface with the system
and that it has really accelerated their
research now this isn't only good for
ancient greek texts but the more we
learn and how we can use ai in order to
accelerate other fields i think the
better the success rates for all of
science this goes along with an open
access paper in nature that you can read
the code is online you can try it out
for yourself and they even have a
website with a little demo application
or you can try it out yourself and just
in case you happen to have some ancient
greek block laying around with some
damages in it just enter it here it will
it will do it it will predict it overall
i think it's a pretty cool trend what
deepmind is doing interfacing with lots
of experts in adjacent and even
non-adjacent fields and using ai in
order to come up with accelerations in
those fields i think it's a neat
application and it benefits everyone
the verge writes ai suggested 40 000 new
possible chemical weapons in just six
hours now this is an interview with the
author of this commentary here it is
called dual use of artificial
intelligence-powered drug discovery so
what has happened here is that there is
a lot of research in drug discovery and
ai accelerated drug discovery obviously
and the mission there is to come up with
compounds that achieve some sort of an
effect while also not being toxic it's a
good property to have not being toxic
and what often is done is that there are
toxicity data sets so explicitly labeled
substances and how toxic they are and
what those people can do is they can
essentially take those data sets and
train a classifier an auxiliary
classifier that helps their method avoid
toxicity so neural network a would try
to come up with new compounds and then
neural network b would just reduce the
likelihood of the ones that are really
toxic so you can imagine almost like a
little bit of a regularizer or a loss
component for the generative model of
new compounds now all that these
researchers did is simply flip the sign
essentially in front of that auxiliary
classifier so instead of coming up with
new compounds that go less toxic these
new compounds go more toxic and what's
interesting is that they observe that
this system will immediately give them
lots of substances that have been used
for doing chemical warfare and also a
couple of instances of substances that
are more toxic than the nerve agent vx
which is very lethal compound in very
very small doses it paralyzes your lungs
and you dead so this is quite concerning
because of the easiness of how that is
to do essentially if you are a little
bit into drug discovery and you can
handle a bit of machine learning this is
relatively simple to do the more hard
part here is to actually synthesize
those molecules although that is also
not too difficult as the article alludes
the article is necessarily kept not very
detailed in order to not just you know
throw out exactly how to do it but it is
implied that anyone with a bit of
knowledge of the topic could go about
doing this and this comes back to what
i've been saying for a while i didn't
invent this opinion but i was always
saying that any technology can be used
for good and for bad with like a few
tiny pieces of exception the goodness or
badness of the technology is almost two
sides of the same coin and this lays it
pretty bare essentially any method that
we have to make ai technologies somehow
more beneficial less toxic more truthful
more reliable anything like this any
method like this that is usually hailed
if you usually just flip a sign on
something you flip one bit in the
objective you can achieve the exact
opposite there are very few techniques
where you cannot directly derive a more
quote-unquote evil method from a
quote-unquote good method not to me i
think just raises a set of important
questions and i think it requires us to
rethink a little bit how we deal with ai
safety and with undesirable consequences
of research but if you have an opinion
let me know in the comments
gary marcus writes in nautilus deep
learning is hitting a wall this is an
essay an opinion piece essentially by
gary marcus who is a longtime ai
researcher and author and public persona
if you've been an ai for a while you've
certainly heard of him he's usually
pitched as a little bit of an antagonist
to the current paradigm of just do deep
learning and scale it up big and this
article right here lays out some of his
arguments but also ends on an optimistic
note of the future of deep learning and
its combination with symbolic methods
the core story thread of the article is
gary marcus recalling people like
jeffrey hinton being very pro symbolic
methods and combining symbolic methods
with neural networks let's say back in
the day so symbolic methods contrary to
continuous or distributed methods would
be methods where you can explicitly
manipulate discrete symbols the extreme
version of this would be things like
logical systems or expert systems now
these can get quite complicated in that
you can have symbols which themselves
are functions over other symbols symbols
that represent abstract concepts and
very complicated parameterized
manipulation of those symbols if you go
to the other extreme which is currently
very popular it is that essentially
continuous distributed representation
systems such as deep neural networks
will be able to do all of the ai tasks
that we could possibly want proponents
of this view would say that if we just
keep scaling up systems like gpt 3 or so
then agi will emerge now what marcus is
pleading for here ultimately is that we
need a synthesis of the two methods in
order to progress in the field of ai now
this in itself i don't think is that
controversial people i think are well
aware that deep learning has some
limitations especially let's call it
pure deep learning just scaling up and
feeding more data and obviously some
tasks are tackled way better by symbolic
methods however this article has created
quite a stir on social media lots of
people commenting on it getting into a
little bit of fights about it and i've
been trying to understand what's going
on right here so my conclusions are not
as much as the content of the article is
necessarily wrong or the conclusions
that we need the synthesis is out of the
ordinary however the framing is such
that marcus tends to be quite critical
of the recent advances in the
distributed systems so in the deep
neural networks and what i think is
unreasonably bullish on symbolic methods
and their appeals now as i said the
storyline goes very much with the
development of jeff hinton who at one
point apparently has been more pro
fusing symbolic methods with neural
networks and then somehow has
transitioned into discarding symbolic
methods more and more saying that neural
networks will essentially be able to do
it all to do reasoning to do
understanding etc now i think this
itself is a little bit also of a
one-sided framing of jeff hinton's views
but you can definitely see how jeff
hinton is a strong advocate for neural
systems and for distributed systems
doing these things and have various
points to make right here i think one of
the fundamental questions is that
obviously we all know that for some
tasks we need some kind of symbolic
logical reasoning it can't just all be
done like latently and so on because
well we observe ourselves and we
ourselves do symbolic logic reasoning so
point one is that even though we do
symbolic reasoning it is implemented in
neural hardware in fact nowhere in the
brain is there an explicit symbolic
processor so all the evidence we have is
that even though symbolic manipulation
might be going on in the brain it is
emergent from the underlying
neurological structure now does that
mean we have to go the same route in
deep learning in that we train the
neurological structure to do these
symbolic manipulations or does it mean
we could take a shortcut and directly
implement these symbolic manipulations
by itself i don't know i'm just saying
the precedent is that everything in the
brain as far as we see is implemented
using a neural distributed architecture
and not an explicit symbolic one on the
other hand the brain obviously consists
of super duper specialized parts all
interacting in very sparse and
structured manners and the current deep
learning systems that we have are
essentially very fully connected very
homogeneous systems which are also very
unlike the brain so the argument only
counts about half the next thing is and
somewhat of an issue i have with
symbolicists or let's call it hybridists
attacking deep learning in that they
tend to be a little bit too dismissive
of the abilities of deep learning and
the example that often comes up is
something like gpt-3 now obviously it's
easy to go ahead and criticize gpt3 it
exhibits many failure cases whether it
represents a really bad therapist or
just invents fact out of thin air but i
think there wasn't really a person in
the world that wasn't a little bit at
least surprised by just how much it can
do like of course in hindsight you can
always say well it's just a bigger
version of gpt2 well it just kind of
recites its training examples and i
agree it does it kind of recites and
mushes its training examples i
personally think humans don't do that
much more but there are definitely
emergent phenomena for example the sheer
ability to in context learn as well as
it does that emerge just purely out of a
function of the scale and not because we
built anything explicitly in and i think
when people are very bullish on neural
methods what they refer to is this
ability this emergence of functionality
that we previously thought could only be
explicitly implemented by a symbolic
approach and that just arise if we scale
things up now it is true our ability to
scale things up especially the
exponential scaling that we require for
deep learning has come to a little bit
of a stop since now it takes entire
giant companies to implement one of
those things and it's not clear how we
can scale that up 10x 100x or 1000x more
but that doesn't necessarily dismiss the
claim marcus also criticizes things like
if gpg3 has all these failure modes then
you know be careful about wanting this
in your self-driving car and i think
those miss a little bit what we're going
for gpt-3 is aimed to produce text as if
it were found on the internet and that's
what you're getting if people expect to
get a truthful or factual or helpful
answer out of gpt3 that fundamentally
misses what it was trained for now if
someone sat me in a car and said this
car was trained on driving like human
drivers and we filtered out all the
human drivers that got into accident and
it has really learned well how to
replicate the human driving ability then
i'd be
quite comfortable because that's exactly
what i want i want the car to drive like
a human would drive so there's much less
of a mismatch of what the thing is
trained for and what i'm using the thing
for and therefore i think at least half
of the criticism leveraged here is not
really applicable to something like
self-driving cars the other half is and
likewise marcus uh brings up the net
hack challenge right here as an example
for how deep methods are still way
behind symbolic methods mentioning that
in the net hack challenge these symbolic
methods way outperformed the deep
learning methods by the way if you don't
know nethack is this little game that is
largely text based or at least
ascii-based and you have to do
exploration you have to do long-term
reasoning and so on now what i find a
little bit worth mentioning is that
these symbolic methods that actually won
they are just handcrafted they are and
i'm sure the neural methods to an extent
are two but these symbolic methods are
just bought for the game they just
implement uh the game they parse the
messages they list items they have they
have heuristics for battle for doing
anything essentially everything is
hard-coded this is the boston dynamics
of netac and i think that kind of misses
the point of why we're trying to get
deep learning to do these types of
things because deep learning they are
largely more general methods that we
could apply to any sort of environment
and this just happens to be like a very
defined environment the net hack
environment where everything is super
bounded and all the inputs are extremely
expected and parsable yet deep learning
has the potential to be much more
generalizable and much more applicable
to multiple things at the same time
whereas a bot like this you couldn't
transfer to even a similar game so i
think that kind of criticism is a bit
weak too now the article by marcus ends
on a high note saying for the first time
in 40 years i finally feel some optimism
about a.i as recounting that after the
symbolic methods had been almost a
little bit frowned upon by the community
they do make a resurgence and hybrid
approaches do seem to be promising a
interesting area for the future and with
that i agree and i think the article
itself is a cool read if you are
interested more in marcus's arguments
and a little bit of the history as he
sees it please give it a read
deepmind releases go for sight which is
a language model that supports its
answers with verified quotes this is a
language model that will go out and
search for information as you query it
and it will first of all base its
answers on these citations but second of
all also be able to actually serve you
the citations now this is not the first
kind of its system uh there have been
other attempts at doing this and this is
just one in this iteration but it is an
interesting approach these language
models they do tend to hallucinate a
bunch of facts because there's always a
conflicting interest between the
language model objective and sort of the
let's call it factual consistency and if
you go deeper that is a mismatch between
the model wanting to be grammatical but
also kind of good at reciting whatever
is in the data and so sometimes that
leads to hallucinated facts and this can
be drastically reduced if you base
whatever you produce on actual citations
that exist somewhere now this has
advantages and disadvantages obviously
the advantages you'll be more accurate
on some of these questions uh you'll be
able to provide the user directly with
the citation that you base your
reasoning on however there are also
things that don't work so well what they
discuss here is an example that it says
what does drinking red bull gave you and
the answer being wings is wrong because
there is a citation but obviously
drinking red bull doesn't give you wings
however this is the type of argument
that i also don't quite buy because if i
go to a human and i ask them you know
what does drinking red bull give you
they will either say diabetes or wings i
don't see why we place such a focus on
evaluating these language models on like
factual truthfulness when we query them
with questions that really imply not a
factual truthfulness but sort of the
truthfulness according to common lore or
what advertisement tells us i mean for
all intents and purposes if a human gave
you this answer you would be happy if
that was the question that you asked so
these things being brought up as
negative examples are kind of shady to
me what i can imagine it also doesn't do
that well is give you answers where you
need to synthesize multiple passages
multiple things of citations although
i'm pretty sure you could extend the
system to pull all kinds of citations
maybe actually already do that but the
main focus really seems to be on going
out finding some citations that actually
answers your questions and then gives
you that another cool thing about these
systems is that you don't need to
encapsulate all their knowledge into
their parameters at training time so
they can potentially even answer
questions about topics they've never
seen during training simply by you
providing them with more external
sources that they can query at inference
time so go for site was here able to
answer questions about itself so that's
very cool
in other news mila writes that professor
joshua benjo was appointed knight of the
legion of honor by france this is one of
the highest honors that france gives out
obviously benjoy is canadian but he
fosters a lot of collaboration between
france and canada and it's really cool
to see him honored once more speaking of
joshua banjo meta ai has tweeted out a
little clip and a little advertisement
for a discussion that was moderated by
alex friedman between yom laka and
joshua benjo they've tagged all the
people on twitter now joshua banjo is
not on twitter and you know good for him
but
they've just gone with the first result
that popped up in the search which is a
parody account of a board benjo
so i don't know why but i just find this
really funny please follow board benj on
twitter if the account gets enough
followers we can maybe bully the real
banjo to also get on twitter
andrew main released a cool blog post
titled building games and apps entirely
through natural language using openai's
code davinci model so this is
essentially an exploration of openai's
codex model that can take in natural
language and produce code and andrew has
used this to build various games and
it's pretty cool to see for example here
is a minimal legend of zelda that was
built using this input right here that's
it that's the input there are various
other projects such as a wordle clone a
matrix rain effect tic-tac-toe an image
manipulation tool and much more what i
find really interesting is that you
can't really yet describe the
application you want in natural language
as a non-programmer would do but you
still very much have to speak like a
programmer essentially you have to write
all the comments that go with your code
and the model will simply implement that
stuff for you so this might be an
artifact of how it's trained and could
definitely help programmers in the
future however it also shows we're not
quite at the point yet where a
non-programmer could sit down and use
one of these models to build an
application
the eu search engine has added a little
tool that's called you write that helps
you write stuff so you input whatever
you want here and you'll get out a text
and i thought we'll just make the title
of this video
be whatever you write outputs so we'll
go to the article about the toxic
compounds
we'll just kind of copy
the thing here we'll paste it here
we want a title
our audience is
youtube we want a tone that is
persuasive
let's go ai threatens biological arms
race why not why not
let it be the title so if you want to
try out you write then go to you.com
search for how to write well currently
you is in beta so sign ups are free for
now i don't know for how long more
chorus has a blog post called making
deep learning go
from first principles and yes you have
to pronounce
so the theme of the blog post is that
lots of people have either superstitious
uh ideas of how to accelerate deep
learning or they just kind of know some
tricks from somewhere like oh just use
whatever function here instead of that
other function or in place operations
are better or non-in-place operations
are better and this blog post goes into
details in how you can think about deep
learning performance and by that i mean
like things going fast and things being
efficient from first principles by
thinking about how compute and memory
and transfer between accelerators and
cpus interact and so on it's a pretty
good read and if you're interested i
definitely recommend that you check it
out
related andrei corport he has released a
new blog post in which he goes about
recreating
one famous paper of jan laka from 1989
about handwritten digit recognition with
convolutional neural networks this is
also very cool because kerpati
implements the original model as much as
he can decipher from the original paper
and tries to reproduce those results i
have to say he does get pretty close and
then he goes ahead and implements all of
the things that we've learned so far
about deep learning about how to tweak
architectures and so on and he's able to
bring down the validation loss by quite
a bit so in the end he gets i think over
a 60 reduction in validation error by
implementing all of the newer techniques
and finally also scaling up the data
sets of it he draws some conclusions and
finally concludes with a bit of an
outlook instead of looking 30 years into
the past looking 30 years into the
future trying to extrapolate a little
bit of what the world of deep learning
and ai might look like then looking back
to now it's a pretty cool read and a
pretty cool project definitely recommend
you check it out
the university of copenhagen has a press
release about their paper called pick
grunts reveal their emotions this is
about a system that has a data set of
pick grunts with annotations of whether
pigs are happy or not or surprised or
anxious and it develops a system to
classify these things so all in all this
is a pretty cool application of deep
learning and it turns out short grunts
are happy grunts who knew i guess
farmers knew all along but you know who
knew
the google ai blog has a post about
using deep learning to annotate the
protein universe now whereas systems
like alpha fold have generated a lot of
buzz there are a lot of different tasks
in the macro molecules or more
specifically the protein area of biology
the one tackled here is the question of
what kind of function does a protein
have and what domains within the protein
exhibit those functions so the paper is
about recent advances by google to build
systems that would annotate such
sequences and proteins with their
respective functions and push the state
of the art by quite a bit now for that
they use interestingly enough dilated
convolutional networks and they
emphasize that a big part of getting
this research to be successful is to
actually
also care for the implementation and the
architecture but also there's a big part
in data set preparation and really
validating your approach really making
sure that what you do is effective and
valid it's a pretty cool read and along
with it goes a larger a little bit of a
website blog post a little bit like a
distilled article that is interactive
that you can read and that contains some
hands-on demonstrations where you can
learn about the architecture learn about
the results and explore a little bit by
yourself
jeff atwood and john carmack have made a
bet the bet is whether or not by january
1st 2030 completely autonomous
self-driving cars meeting level 5 fully
self-driving specification will be
commercially available for passenger use
in major cities in this instance john
carmack is 4 and jeff atwood is against
now i have to say
2030 isn't that far away and as jeff
atwood points out fully self-driving is
a really hard problem however as other
people point out in some major cities
you're already available to call
something like a robo taxi which doesn't
seem to be too far away from what's
needed but that might just appear so
because again the gap between driving in
controlled conditions on terrain and
roads that you know where you have exact
specifications of everything and being
able to handle most situations that a
human driver would encounter anywhere at
all times that's a big difference i'm
not sure how this bet is gonna turn out
that's why it's interesting but i'm
interested to hear your opinions in the
comments
[Music]
all right lastly we'll get to some
helpful things helpful things for this
week rubrics is an open source platform
for data centric nlp mostly specifying
with managing text data and annotating
it kubrick is a scalable data set
generator for video and 3d data composer
is a pi torch library for efficient
neural network training they implement a
lot of the recent advances in speedups
of training and give you reproducible
and accessible baselines for you to
implement your own very speedy training
loops mojoco is a physics simulation
library but i guess you already knew
that however as we've reported deepmind
took over bought essentially mojoco and
is releasing it open source and now
they've implemented python bindings so
you're just able to do pip install mujo
co we've been waiting for this for
decades
thank you mctx is monte carlo to
research in jax paddle standing for
pipeline abstractions for deep learning
is a deep learning library that in its
own words makes working with deep
learning models intuitive simple and fun
and it is entirely cross-compatible with
the entire pi torch and scientific
python ecosystem did its spill as a
library for pytorch that checks if you
have any test samples that were in the
training set speaking of pytorch pytorch
releases version 1.11 with the addition
of torch data and funk torch now these
things have been brewing for a while but
it's pretty cool to see them added to
the library torch data is a library a
bunch of functions that make it really
easy to do various data set loading
composing and transforming things
directly in the data loading pipeline
whereas funktorch is a library that adds
composable function transforms to
pytorch a little bit in the flavor of
jacks so definitely check out both
alright that was already it for the
helpful things and ml news this episode
is already way too long thank you for
sticking around
check out gtc use the link sign up win
some merch or 30 90. and i'll see you
around thank you bye bye
[Music]
bye